[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bring me the lab your life begins now
[Music]
Aladin
[Music]
you really don't know who I am genie
wishes land none of their ring it about
you're kidding me he said that to your
face to my face and then what happens I
get real close right I'm like I don't
care which Cabbage Patch you're from Oh
give me back my viewmaster before I
knock the dimples off your face you are
I don't care bear you see the new movie
trailer for what you ain't see it see
what what is it my donkey butt they're
making another Toy Story movie no I
thought those movies would dawn dog they
made three movie didn't make three
movies this is number four Oh toy
stories Martha Jane what about Buzz
Lightyear stuff I am Buzz Lightyear
Space Ranger and what he's like to
infinity and your mom that's not right
you sure no that's not right I'm pretty
sure that's it let me show you to
insanity and blonde what do you even
hey guys you got it all wrong it's to
infinity and beyond impossible nothing
about science
[Music]
everything the light touches is our
kingdom but a king's time is ruler
rises and falls like the Sun one day the
Sun was set on my time here
and will rise with you as the new king
[Music]
remember our word has never been in more
danger
[Music]
human worried is what drove us
underground all those years ago to
escape from your rapacious appetite
[Music]
I warn you boy
[Music]
you are not prepared for the truth
behind what you seek
[Music]
no you will be
- as fair
[Music]
[Music]
you've got red wow this place is amazing
what a buzz gonna meet us here he must
be held up somewhere hey up here Astro
Boy if you think you can take our top
prize spot your room dead wrong
help me get out of here
[Music]
[Music]
welcome baby Dumbo we're all family here
no matter how small
[Music]
[Music]
yes something very rare
you have wonder
[Music]
you have to sneak
[Applause]
you have magic
[Music]
come with me
together we can soar on the elephant's
wings
what's happening were they taking her
take Dumbo back inside but she's his mom
do something she needs us look at me
we're gonna bring your mama huh
he doesn't look like magic to me
[Music]
you don't need you to believe in
you can do a Dumbo shows
[Applause]
sly baby
[Music]